come on how is this possible she looks
exactly the same et was on the set of J
Lo's Cosmo photoshoot back in 1998 she
has had quite the Hollywood journey and
we've been there from the very start
here's when we first met Jennifer Lopez
I went from being a fly girl which is it
didn't happen overnight I was in show
business since I was out of high school
[Music]
a short permed bob full eyebrows and
slightly nervous
that was JLo when we first met her in
1990 21 years old auditioning to be a
Fly Girl on in living color fast forward
six years Jenny from the block had made
the transition from TV to the movies I
don't know you walk in the room and they
love you and that's it she's the one no
I have to read like 17 times I have some
bend over backwards hi Entertainment
Tonight I'm Jennifer Lopez and you are
on the set of Selena I'll be playing no
JLo invited et cameras to join her she
got ready for the big Selena premiere
where's my husband check out how excited
she was telling then husband Aulani Noah
about the rocks that she got would
somebody tell him that this is real baby
made-up middle put it down hit the thumb
yang Mena real from behind the scenes of
her films to onset of her music videos
to red carpet fashion look after look
we've been there for all the most iconic
moments of JLo's life like this one
that is the dress I know right this is
it this is hot you know just felt right
it was a good-looking dress you know Ana
and the thing was it wasn't as open as
it looked on TV cause with the
three-quarter angle I was giving to a
camera because I could see inside which
was fine I don't care
she's always been open hard-working and
focused and you know we've learned a lot
from Jennifer like when you fall down
you just gotta get back up remember this
moment from the 2009 AMAs the furthest
thing from my mind was that I would slip
I mean literally if you if you slow
motion that thing I go for so much air I
thought I was Michael Jordan I mean I
love the fact that you popped up and
you're like let's go yeah another lesson
sure all this is great but it really
starts on the inside I know for sure
that you have to love yourself first if
you don't love yourself really nothing's
gonna go right you're gonna make great
choices for our kids because we love
them so much we got to do the same thing
for ourselves
and then when it comes to relationships
JLo's shown us that you got to love big
to stay friendly with the exes and never
give up because one day you will meet
your soul mate do you believe in love at
first sight
yeah I do I think sometimes you know you
meet somebody in the minute you see them
and they see you just something happens
I think we're very alike in many ways
and I think that's what makes it work
we're likely except I can't say dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]